1 philippe laurent bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france 6 milliards d'euros
sur trois ans comment est ce que vous
avez voilà sur quelle base
vous êtes vous
avez vous trouvé cette estimation ces
chiffres ont écouté il s'agit simplement
de la prise en compte de calcul assez
simple en définitive vous savez qu'en
2020 les communes ont donc perdu des
ressources notamment parce que les
services ont été fermées et que donc
nous avons continué à payer les charges
à payer des personnels ce qui était
normal mais en revanche nous n'avons pas
pu facturé tarifs et les services que
nous apportons aux familles vous savez
que les communes sont dans un cas
particulier dans l'est dans les
administrations publiques
ce sont les seuls qui organise des
services en direction de la population
et qui tarifs ses services alors au coût
de revient parfois même très bas par
rapport au coût de revient il ya quand
même des tarifs et donc par conséquent
la perte de recettes tarifaires a été de
plus de deux milliards d'euros et cette
perte cela n'a absolument pas été
compensés par l'état
malgré deux demandes il ya d'autres
pertes qui sont également survenus sur
toutes les pertes qui concerne les
recettes des transports en commun les
transports publics
elles ont été compensées en partie oui
mais pas de piment et puis enfin sur le
plan des impôts locaux et bien il ya un
certain nombre d'impôts locaux qui ne
pourront pas être perçue je pense
notamment aux impôts sur les entreprises
à partir notamment de 2021 et 2022
puisqu'il ya un décalage
voilà donc au total tout ceci si on
additionne les dépenses supplémentaires
si on enlève les économies puisqu'il eut
quelques économies réalisées ça nous
fait 6 milliards sur l'ensemble des
collectivités locales sur trois ans y at
il des communes plus touchés que
d'autres on pense notamment à certaines
villes certaines communes qui sont
plutôt rustique que d'autres les
communes touristiques pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles ont compensé par
les ont pas toutes touchées de la même
manière revanche les communes qui ont
été le plus touchés finalement ce sont
des communes moyennes qui apporte des
services relativement importants à leurs
habitants centre de loisirs les écoles
les cantines les crèches etc et qui donc
perdre cette recette tarifaires sont
plutôt ces communes là qui sont qui ont
été touchés dans la mesure où vous avez
beaucoup de services aux habitants
vous avez forcément des conséquences
ensuite vous aurez également
ddd communaux des intercommunalités qui
seront concernés ce sont des
intercommunalités notamment industriels
là où des usines ont pu être fermée
pendant un certain temps notamment en
2020 avec un décalage qu'il voulait sont
des pertes qui se fera sur 2021 et 2022
parce que le système est ainsi fait
c'est plutôt ce genre de communes voyait
des communes touristiques pour beaucoup
d'entre elles ont été compensées par
l'état
le député lrm jean rené cazeneuve
relativise un petit peu le conseil
précise que des économies ont aussi été
réalisées pendant cette crise sanitaire
je cite et puis sinon municipales
fermées c'est des entrées en moins mais
c'est aussi l'entretien et des coûts
évités donc 6 milliards d'euros de
manque à gagner c'est également de
l'argent qui représente peut-être 1 25%
des recettes annuelles du bloc communal
qu'est ce que vous en pensez êtes vous
d'accord
alors bien sûr il ya des jeux les dix il
ya eu quelques échos de mai réalisé par
exemple le fait de ne pas avoir organisé
de manifestation ou de fait par exemple
pendant au printemps dernier au
printemps 2002 2020 arrêt a fait
réaliser quelques essais de demi mais
jean-rené cazeneuve le c'est bien parce
que nous en avons souvent parlé ensemble
une piscine qui est fermé d'abord il
faut continuer à payer le personnel et
nous n'avons pas la compensation par le
chômage partiel vous savez mais qui est
versée par l'état aux entreprises ça ça
n'existe pas pour la fonction publique
donc je condamne à payer le personnel et
une ont une piscine ça continue à
s'entretenir même lorsqu'elles les
peines ne fonctionne pas il faut
continuer à entretenir les machines le
matériel les systèmes de 2,2
comment dirais-je de gestion des eaux
enfin tout ça
nous nous avons eu nous avons parce que
nous devons le faire juridiquement
d'ailleurs ses obligations on a bien
procédé à la vidange de la piscine comme
si elle était comme s'ils continuent à
fonctionner parce que c'est les textes
qui nous la pause est d'ailleurs celle
sur des textes normaux il n'y a pas de
on ne conteste pas ça donc on a bien dû
continuer toute façon entretenir il n'y
a pas eu beaucoup d'économies réalisées
de ce point de vue là qu'attends tu es
qu'attendez vous d'eux
exécutif et qu'elle pourrait être selon
vous les solutions adaptées pour limiter
la casse alors d'abord ce que nous
disons au gouvernement c'est que si les
communes se trouvent trop en difficulté
et notamment voit baisser leurs
capacités d'investissement
ça sera pas bon pour la relance donc le
gouvernement souhaite que les communes
soient parmi les fers de lance de la
relance nous en sommes d'accord nous
avons des projets mais s'il n'y a pas
les financements nécessaires et si nous
perdons trop de recettes
on ne pourra pas le faire il faut être
clair il faut que tout le monde soit
terre donc ce que nous souhaitons c'est
que le gouvernement prenne conscience
que le gouvernement donc discutent avec
nous pour mettre en place un système de
compensation des pertes que nous avons
enregistrées en 2020 on ne demande pas
de l'argent supplémentaire on demande
simplement on discute sur les
compensations des pertes enregistrées en
2020 et que nous enregistrerons encore
en 2021 voir en 2022
c'est exactement ça c'est ce qui nous
permettra de conserver notre capacité
qu'on appelle d'autofinancement pour
pouvoir relancer l'investissement et
ainsi donc participer pleinement à la
relance dans des secteurs qui sont ce
que tout le monde souhaite à savoir la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
notamment des bâtiments scolaires
l'environnement etc
nous savons nous avons tous des projets
en portefeuille mais là aussi si on n'a
pas les moyens de l'est est suffisamment
d'apport en ressources propres
même si on peut légèrement augmenté
l'emprunt eh bien nous ne devrons pas
basculer berne ne joueront pas les pieds
merci beaucoup philippe laurent d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de soues et secrétaire
général de l'aeem f
l'association des maires de france